-My next guest
is a very talented actor
starring in the new movie,
"The Dry,"
which opens in theaters
and on demand May 21st.
Here he is, Eric Bana.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's what
I'm talking about, bud.
Hey!
-Hi, Jimmy.
-It's great to see you, bud.
I like your room.
This is the kind of
fun thing about Zooms.
I get to see the room.
I like --
-Well, I got to say,
it's pretty unique,
just coming down
a flight of stairs
instead of flying 24 hours
to be on the show,
so this is pretty cool.
[ Laughter ]
-You are -- What time
is it now in Australia?
-It's about 7:30 in the morning.
-Wow.
Thank you for doing our morning
show, "The Tonight Show."
I appreciate that.
-It's a pleasure.
-Is it 7:30 in the morning
tomorrow for me, or is it today?
Who's living in the --
-No, it's tomorrow, mate.
You're time-traveling.
It's tomorrow.
What day is it here?
I've lost track.
But, yeah, we're ahead, mate.
We're ahead on everything.
Okay?
So just -- you have to remember
we're ahead.
-What's the future like?
What do I have
to look forward to?
-Well, I can tell you that
right now, even though,
you know,
we're still in the pandemic,
I'm able to go to the football
every week and watch my team
play with 30,000
or 40,000 other people.
So I guess that is what the
future looks like for you, also.
-Wow, that's fantastic.
Can you also --
Just six random lottery numbers,
just to give to us.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, no.
-All right,
you don't want to do that.
What have you --
How is quarantine treating you?
Did you go a little crazy,
or were you good at home?
-Do you know what?
I'd like to think
that I represent a little bit
of a balance for your audience.
And I'd like to make them
feel better about themselves,
if I can share this, Jimmy.
I did nothing.
[ Laughter ]
I did not bake any sourdough.
I did not paint.
I did not start a podcast.
I did not plant a veggie garden.
I did not upload a yoga video.
I did not do a yoga video.
I did nothing.
-That's exactly right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's what I --
See?
Wow.
And now --
Now that you can do something,
what are you doing?
-Well, besides going
to the football,
I think the first thing
I did was,
I was just dying
to get out on one of my bikes.
So I went mountain biking
with a buddy of mine.
And we had such a strict
lockdown here where you couldn't
travel more than 2 or 3 miles
from your home,
and we had a curfew,
so when it broke,
and you could get out,
it was kind of like crazy.
It was like a scene
out of "Mad Max."
It was like, "I just need
to burn some gasoline.
I just need to just burn --"
It was crazy out there.
It was just like
"Mad Max 2," you know?
-Just piles of bonfires.
-Whipping across the desert,
yeah.
-I want to talk about
your new movie, "The Dry."
Congrats. It's got amazing
reviews on Rotten Tomatoes.
I think it's like 95%.
It's a hit already in Australia.
[ Applause ]
It is based off
of the best-selling book.
-Yeah, so I read the book
by Jane Harper and loved it.
And we just desperately wanted
to turn this into, like,
a big cinematic version
of the story, which we did.
And it was a huge hit
here in Australia,
and we hope that American
audiences enjoy it.
I tell you want, you can't
fly to Australia right now,
but at the end of this film,
you're gonna feel like
you spent a couple hours
in Australia
in a little country town.
That's a promise.
-So is it almost
also like a travel movie,
is what you're saying?
-Well, our depiction of this
fictitious town of Kiewarra
is so accurate, you are gonna
feel like you were here.
It is a whodunnit,
and I play a detective
who's returning home because of
the funeral of his best friend.
And we get
the impression straightaway
that he's not welcome.
And we find out that he's linked
to a crime in the past.
So there's kind of like
two crimes, one in the present,
one in the past
that need to be solved.
And the audience
will have some fun
trying to work out
what happened.
-Yeah, and who sent you the note
and all this stuff.
It's --
It's just insane.
I love stuff like this.
I'm going to freak out.
And we got a trailer sent to us,
so it's like you get a card
that says, like, "You've got
to come to the funeral.
You lied, Luke lied."
That's it.
-Yeah, and it's
got this sense of --
-I'm in, I'm in, I'm in, I'm in!
If I get that, I go,
"What? What, what?!"
Wow, I'm in.
-Yeah, it has that sense of,
like, having been forced
to go to a school reunion
you don't want to.
'Cause I'm having to return
to the country town
that I grew up in
like 20 years ago
and try and uncover the truth
of what occurred.
And Genevieve O'Reilly is
in the film with me,
and she's incredible, as well,
in this amazing cast.
But you will feel like
you've spent a couple of hours
in Australia by the time
you finish with this film.
-Well, congrats
on the great reviews, buddy.
And I want
to show everyone a clip.
Here's Eric Bana
in "The Dry."
Take a look at this.
-I was just closing up, dude.
Do you want something?
-No, I'm okay.
I'll just, um...
My dad used to work here
when I was a kid,
so I was just reminiscing,
you know?
-Falk.
-Yeah -- Aaron.
-Dr. Leigh, Chris Leigh.
-Right.
-So you knew the Hadlers?
-Yeah, you know everyone
in this job.
-Yeah, sometimes too well,
I bet.
-[ Chuckles ]
-Hey, I was wondering,
with, um --
with Luke,
any obvious signs of distress?
With Karen?
Bruising or anything?
-You know I can't tell you that.
Welcome home.
-Thanks.
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on!
Eric Bana, everybody!
Check out "The Dry,"
in theaters and on demand
this Friday.
Have the best day, bud!
Thanks you so much
for coming on our show.
-Thank you, mate.